ow yeah you dirty dirty man
okay what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Aubrey Plaza
you know her from standout roles in
films like anger goes west Scott Pilgrim
vs. the world it shows like Parks and
Recreation and many more you can catch
her in FX's Legion which returns for its
third season on July 1st and she's very
busy she also stars in child's play
which is set to theaters this weekend
I'll replies oh welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me you once
told BuzzFeed that your favorite pizza
topping is hot and spicy peppers do you
crank your wings too I what oh I said
don't believe everything you read right
I've never talked to BuzzFeed a day in
my life I don't even know who that is
[Music]
so this first one is the classic and
we'll start up the handle at the handle
mm-hmm of the wing of this whole thing
okay Jeremy watch meet the whole thing
or if you'd like to
[Music]
so all showbiz origin stories are insane
in their own right but especially yours
going from a waitress working in Queens
to all of a sudden landing Parks and
Recreation funny people and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world in the same exact
week did cycling through jobs in the
restaurant industry do anything to help
you prepare for career in Hollywood or
is it just a way to pay the bills while
you sought out auditions hmm
I was kind of both like every table was
like a new performance an opportunity
for performance you know I didn't have
to like be myself I could be whoever I
wanted to be I'm gonna try to get as
much money as I could it was like a game
I like those kinds of games which pre
fame job do you remember more fondly
when you were a hostess at Joe's Crab
Shack or when you're a cocktail waitress
who told you that an alley
who are you I was a hostess so I was in
charge of announcing like the party's
when they were ready so I was on like
the loud speaker going like Johnson
party of six do the crab walk all the
way to the host and your tables ready
Johnson party of six you still got it
thank you
but every time there were certain songs
that would come on that the entire
waitstaff would have to do like a song
and dance to like two slides to the left
four hops at this time thought whatever
that song is classic classic gives me
nightmares now
sauce Bay so on the topic of the new
movie when you're growing up and working
in the now-defunct classic video store
in Delaware Avenue did you have an
interest or nostalgia in the child's
play hullraiser Freddy Krueger Golden
Age in horror really have that interest
I wasn't really like a horror movie
person ever
I'm gonna still not do you believe in
ghosts or if you had any sort of spooky
paranormal encounter I know that you
grew up next to a cemetery but there you
gonna say 7-eleven which is also true is
like guys been a lot of time in that
parking lot yeah I believe in ghosts my
cat was hit by a car and then a couple
weeks later crawled right out of the
cemetery right back onto our back deck
and you know when that happens you just
have to let it let her inside and go
like cool I wonder if this is like your
seventh life or your ninth one cuantos
my pepper sauce it'd be really like not
satisfying if I had just no reaction to
any of these wings right but it would
also be pretty amazing oh I know that
you do have an amazing I have a nice
well I don't think anybody has ever
sought out for that specific goal but
maybe you could be the fun that's trying
to do anything here I'm just eating
whatever you tell me to I just do
whatever you tell me okay try to keep a
straight face as long as it can okay
okay so the fans would give us a red
card and kick us off the internet if we
didn't take a wing to discuss April
Ludgate your iconic character from Parks
and Recreation okay what do you think
was the greatest on-set prank of all
time whether it was one of yours or
someone else's I don't know if you would
call it a prank but Nick Offerman and
Chris Pratt would like fart a lot
classic fart frame it's just like I
don't
sometimes farts are funny I don't know I
guess they are I just don't think
they're that funny
and neither does Amy and without fail
like anytime the two of them were to see
him together
they would part City rip one disgusting
right it would make us so angry and I
would say like the best prank that I
ever did was I bought a toilet goblin
online and I put it in Adam Scott's
toilet and his trailer if you don't know
what a toilet goblin is it's like a
little like creature that it's arms have
like suction cups so you like put it in
the toilet you suction cup its arms to
the lid so that when you open the lid it
like jumps out at you it's terrifying
and then in her book yes please Amy
Poehler said that Chris Pratt had the
greatest audition that she's ever
witnessed have you ever had a chance to
see the tape I feel like they show maybe
showed that at the Reunion but I think I
wasn't paying attention I don't remember
but I'm sure it was good and then there
are so many coveted pieces of Parks and
Rec memorabilia whether it's Leslie's
pawneegoddess hoodie or the baseball bat
that Nick Offerman had made for the
whole cast you have a most treasured
tchotchke from your time on set yes I
had well I stole Janet snake-hole slike
cigarette holder so I have that I keep
that in my backpack at all times I guess
I need it oh I have Andy Dwyer some
aviators and I don't take care of them
at all they're just like flung in a
drawer in my kitchen I could probably
sell those someday if things don't go
well for me which I won't
[Music]
number four already in straight-faced
all the way through so as we touch on a
little bit today what do you think it's
on my teeth oh that's disgusting I'll
tell you my great sure you have milk we
have water you got a coffee cup full of
something just gonna have some coffee
mm-hmm I like black coffee with my
spices it's it's one of the great mixed
yeah it burns so good this is we touched
on a little bit today you went from
relative obscurity to almost overnight
starting alongside some of the biggest
names in entertainment but was anything
more intimidating than following Adam
Sandler your fourth ever time doing
stand-up no that was one of the most
[ __ ] up nights of my life because Jed
Abbott I'll totally duped me he invited
me to the comedy of magic club in
Hermosa Beach and was like just come
with a cast with Jonah and Adam and like
you can watch them we'll just kind of
get into it and then backstage he came
out to me and he was like you're going
on next you're following X and ler and I
was like are you [ __ ] kidding me and
and then Adam came up to me and was like
you got a guy out there that's exactly
what he said you ain't you're gonna die
yeah and he hadn't done stand-up in like
years at that point so the audience gave
him a standing ovation when they just
announced his name he hadn't even said
anything yet and I was sitting behind
the curtain going this is not gonna go
well for me how'd it go for you you know
what am i great I mean when you have
nothing to lose it actually works in
your favor because I didn't have any
credits at that time so when they
announced me they just said like and now
we have Audrey Plaza from Wilmington
Delaware and that was like my
announcement
those calientes a halfway mark here okay
I have a little bit of stuff coming on
my nose does that make you feel good it
does you get pleasure out of this right
yeah yeah that's all I have hmm can't
take it on my team
I'm similarly empty inside you know I
need this you just want you want you
want someone else to feel something so
you can feel exactly I'll rewrap
recurring segments on our show called
explain that grand where we do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram poll
interesting pictures that need more
contact so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture you just saw
Instagram yep all right you just taught
me the bigger story doesn't that sound
good
which one which account is it I know my
public one well I can't get into your
private one good all right here you are
hugging the Jeff Goldblum jurassic park
statue where's security did you get
tasered or what's going on here well if
you if you look at the picture closely
you see that woman in the yellow shirt
is in mid reaction mid action to come
and escort me off the premises his chest
is exposed and the light was just
hitting in a certain way I just felt
like I needed to touch it you're only in
London
standing in front of a giant Jeff
Goldblum statue you once in your life
right um so I just felt like it's now or
never baby had to seize that opportunity
to get into that that's close to the
nipple as possible do you have a lasting
memory from your summer with Zac Efron I
guess like when I think about that shoot
all I remember is just like I have these
like images and Zach with like a TRX
like rig on like a palm tree just like
pump just pumping iron in between takes
and I just remember like standing like
off to the side going like that's a
movie star right there that's the [ __ ]
I'll never be that but I'll be close to
it as close as I can do you have a
crowning athletic achievement from your
time with the pistol shrimps how long do
we have
I mean I'm here i man I went through a
lot on that team is it an achievement to
tear your ACL on the court because that
happened to me that means that you're
pushing it to the limit I push it to the
limit and not only did I tear my ACL but
I was in full disguise I was wearing a
wig and goggles and play
under a different name because legally I
was not allowed to play on that team at
the time so I was in disguise and the
joke ended up being on me because I
ripped my ACL in half and had to go to a
hospital one more for you
grumpy cat how could you bring grumpy
cat up right now at a time like this
because it's important that we don't
forget grumpy yep yeah we can't cuz
grumpy cat died mm-hmm a week ago I'm
still grieving and you know it's messed
up about that is I had written a movie
for grumpy cat and I to star in and now
what am I gonna do without the cat I'm
sorry all right P I'm sorry I brought it
up
Hellfire sounds cute
[Music]
tastes no evil that's hot
okay you got me you were waiting for
that right yeah okay there it is you can
got it so some of the best talk show
guests are the ones that you can almost
see in real-time navigating the artifice
of it all away
sorry Wells a question how has your
relationship with the interview talk
show format evolved over the years you
know I just do the best I can
I tell myself before every interview be
normal Aubrey just be likable
get in there show them what you got and
get out and um somehow it just always go
south I don't know why maybe it's the
lights or just a private deep-seated
psychological trauma hmm are these
organic grass-fed mmhmm
pasture-raised all that hmm you don't
want farm they came from uh well sure
find out later the chilli farm uh-huh
you ain't gon take me down little
chickies I hate all you it's a true that
sometimes like spices come in you
hallucinate
yeah it's that they can be trippy by
starting to feel something no I just see
some weird [ __ ] but I might not be
because of this so whether it's the
media or fans sometimes like if you're
in Hollywood you have a reputation for
being a jerk maybe people tiptoe around
you or if you have a reputation for
being an overshare
maybe people step over those boundaries
the second that they meet you what are
the professional and personal
liabilities of being somebody who's
labeled sarcastic or awkward because of
some of your most popular characters
people because I have this talk show
right oh god that coffees not helping
we're coming in with an emergency
sometimes you can just have anything get
a new and get this way you know like
sometimes because I have this show or
interview celebrities while you'd
increasingly spicy chicken wings people
will just come up to me and be like hey
Sean this new hot sauce is called
shaytans but it's the hottest hot sauce
ever you have to try it out you know
because like I understand you're like I
just want to do a daytime show right I
thought let's talk about the Kardashians
for once exactly but I understand why
people think that but then that is kind
of missing the point
oh I don't know Sean I think the thing
is Rick I just feel like nobody gives me
a chance you know
people think that I but I don't care or
that I can just that I can only be
sarcastic or only play like you know a
deadpan character or something but it's
just not true I play a young mom and
child's play you can see my maternal
instincts on the big screen on June 21st
in theaters near you and if you really
go through my filmography you'll see you
know many different characters with all
different kinds of flavors
los calientes I would say that would be
like a the dirty grandpa version of meme
Shaquanda would be like the mic and day
of character up with the wool shirt
chili farm that we just ate be I go with
anger goes west for that one because
there's like the Los Angeles theme there
have you ever had anyone name their
movies based on the hot sauces no but
that would be able to sign game all
right we're back okay that was a big one
well if you think that was a big one oh
cool you look awesome sweet
does everyone always make it to the end
I've never seen this I've only know
about it from my inbox right from the
emails I get asking me to go on which
you've been able to swerve effectively I
waited until now you've trapped me this
time right so we've been doing this
forever and ever I just don't know if
child's play it will be my last movie so
I figured get it in while I can
oh we really appreciate that but we've
been doing this for so long but
shockingly like fewer than 15 people
have ever tapped out sorry what well I
just want to get a preview first god
that went straight into my lower
intensive it's like anywhere I turn it's
bad there's no hiding huh huh that burns
just being near it ow you dirty dirty
man you at all
trickster mm-hmm let's see what you're
doing with that one salute Wow Aubrey
Plaza going in you know in Puerto Rico
right I know if I if I wasn't on camera
I'd eat these down to the bone my
fingers nothing stop with you on my
family nothing stopping you right baby
just got a little skin there so it's not
every day that we have the most famous
person from Delaware sitting across the
seat from us and that is official that
is an official distinction are you
talking about Biden last year you top to
deliver online poll edging out the likes
of oh my god I'm Valerie Bertinelli and
Joe Biden yeah and the guy that created
the Heimlich maneuver was his name
Walter I think Walter you even tapped
out Walter Walter Heimlich have you ever
been punkin chunkin no I haven't and I
can I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you all sucks
where do you fall on the debate that
North Delaware and South Delaware should
be separate in two different states yes
what is scrapple ow
I'm with you I'm with you oh no no it
had me know what is scrapple me have you
ever had it is it good yeah I had a ball
time
[ __ ] how is the horse-racing scene in
Delaware how does it compare to say like
England's the Royal Ascot I don't care
anymore I turn about point to point
mm-hmm yeah it's [ __ ] up and then
Delaware seems to be a place with a fair
number of ice cream bucket list
destinations whether it's Woodside farm
creamery or that 20 scoop ice cream
challenge at the charcoal pick which one
sounds best right now
charcoal bit I like charcoal bit I like
my mommy
am i handling it
you are yeah that's good with bravery
something coming out of my nose with
composure no you're good am I good am I
having a stroke
I don't think so you're good
can I pour this into my nose oh hell you
can give it a shot call that feel good
did that help
yeah she got y'all lumber camp oh yeah
it was good oh yeah
that's the move anything I can get up my
nose
[Music]
this is this next one [ __ ] you I get it
your [ __ ] mind
I'm a lady okay I'll play around like
that mm-hmm
all right let's go all right so this
one's the chocolate plague okay
number nine careful around your eyes Oh
who's that a bad idea it's someone
playing the saxophone right now cuz I
swear to God I look you better stop
playing the saxophone [ __ ]
that's not our eye on that - I heard
that - hey [ __ ] hell
so damn it what do you think is
Delaware's greatest gift to the American
culinary canon is it that Grotto pizza
or that thanksgiving on a roll sandwich
from capriati's oh [ __ ] it's the [ __ ]
but a Bobby sandwich all the way I mean
grottoes is good but krottas is greasy
I mean crotteaus is like man if you hate
yourself you go in but like it tastes
good
mm-hmm like I'll go to grottoes any day
on February 25th 2010 oh my god you
tweeted that you hadn't used a microwave
in two years have you started using a
microwave again hell yeah i microwave
show last night
shame you're back on the microwave i
exploded a cup of coffee and a microwave
ah saying my eyes are on fire what are
some telltale signs that you're walking
into an awesome Puerto Rican restaurant
uh you know the mofongo is on point if
Oh God if the music's good it's all
about the music
my ads are burning do you think I could
put the milk in my eyes it's not a bad
idea and I have my nose should I put it
in every like hole I think I think we've
gone this far might as well give it a
shot I just don't know how I could do it
without ruining my droning my reputation
can't see anymore ow
this is the last dab we call it the last
stab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
ow
you don't have to if you don't want to I
know you're going through it now how did
this get in my eye
can I have a new napkin yeah napkin duty
napkins it's psychological I think it is
on some level okay but it's also
physical you take me to my happy place
we are eating some of the hottest
scorching hot chicken wings in the
history of exist no not a happy place
grumpy cat and improv and two words
aviator sunglasses all right let's do it
oh we're dabbing we're dabbing it up
[Music]
very deliberate very cautious and it's
not enough for you that's that's plenty
that's funny
good job Audrey hey just want to make
you happy well you have you know I feel
whole now you do
[Music]
Wow
you know alright Aubry Plaza here we are
at the finish line the end in just one
more obstacle to go you have one of the
great poker faces in Hollywood but I've
heard you say that sometimes in order
not to break you'll go into actual
physical pain pinching yourself until
you bleed yeah so oh yeah
so here so I'm gonna show you a series
of pictures and all you have to do is
not break okay
excuse me
[Music]
I knew we were gonna end this on an
awkward not classic that's my classic
signature well look at you though 10
chicken wings up 10 chicken wings down
we ran into a wall here in the back half
but you rallied through went to your
happy place got a new napkin and handled
it thank you so much now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you my friend this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life okay
um while I'm doing a lot of self-care
recently I've been going to a lot of
therapy and I'm just trying to keep my
eye on the prize and not do anything
stupid so you meant yeah maybe if he of
them will be coming out Oh
child's play in theaters on June 21st
what milk up the nose really helped it
actually did it kind of cleared and kind
of shook reclaim like a nut just gotcha
has anyone ever done that before no
you're the first person to ever you
promise I promise
that's scary there for a minute Aloha
spice Lords thank you so much for
watching today's episode this is Sean
Evans checking in with three tips for
surviving summer remember to wear
sunscreen at least an SPF 50 if you're
anything like me don't forget to stay
hydrated when you're out there on the
beach and always have a bottle of the
sauce of summer Lowe's calientes I never
go anywhere without it
heat nice calm heat nice calm to order
los calientes it's muy delicioso
[Music]